[Music]
hello everyone the transition to
greatness has officially begun Friday's
jobs report was encouraging to say the
absolute least the jobs in this country
we had more than 2.5 million added the
prediction was that 7.5 million jobs
would be lost this was a 10 million
swing toward the positive side and in
fact the greatest number of jobs created
in a single month on record that is
extraordinary 225,000 manufacturing jobs
464 thousand construction jobs and 1.2
million leisure and hospitality jobs
were all added in May beyond that the
number of workers who reported being on
temporary layoffs decreased by 2.7
million in May and more than that and
this was a great number that was pointed
out to me today by the CEA three hundred
three hundred thousand jobs were created
for black Americans in particular that's
in May and that was a 1.7 percent
increase so very encouraging numbers
there from the CEA that they highlighted
for me BLS numbers that they highlighted
maize jump in average weekly hours also
is an encouraging sign because
increasing hours is a sign that
employees need to higher employers need
to hire more workers to meet demand for
all private sector employees average
weekly hours increased by 0.5% to thirty
four point seven hours the highest level
since the series began in 2006 73% of
small businesses are open that is up
from the 52 percent right before the
April jobs report reference period also
workplace visits are up roughly 40
percent from its pandemic low the stock
market is absolutely soaring we saw with
the SMP that it had its greatest 50-day
rally in history the Dow likewise is
also booming the markets clearly have
confidence in President Trump the jobs
president who created the hottest
economy a modern history once and we'll
do it again
also commentators and economists have
noted how great this jobs report was
yesterday we saw Mohamed el-erian the
chief economic advisor at Allianz say
this will go down in history
as the biggest positive data shock for
the markets in the economy and you saw
how surprised the markets were they
surged on Friday capping a strong week
with the Nasdaq closing at a record high
he said it was also very surprising to
the economists not a single one thought
that we would create jobs everybody
expected the unemployment rate would go
up it did not also senior economic
correspondent at the New York Times Neil
Irwin noted that we have to think that
the May unemployment the May employment
numbers count as a strong win for PPP
supporters obviously the President
signed that into law and has been a been
a big cheerleader of the PPP typical
economists missed it by 10 million as I
noted at the top of the briefing 10
million that's bigger than the entire
state of Michigan merely and that's how
much economists were off why is this
happening well it's happening because
America has taken note of the fact that
we have a president who ushered in the
hottest economy in modern history
record low unemployment for black
Americans for Hispanic Americans for the
disabled for our veterans paychecks were
beginning to rise under the president
Donald Trump economy we have the great
jobs creator in office and America
clearly has confidence in this president
you have a president who fundamentally
understands how to put this country back
to work and we saw that in action with
the Friday jobs report and with that
I'll take questions so start with John
what's the president's thinking on this
growing movement to either defund or
dismantle police forces across the
country and what reforms does the
president think would be appropriate in
the wake of the George Floyd
yeah it's a really good question the
president is appalled by the defund the
police movement the fact that you have
sitting Congress women wanting to defund
the police notably Rasheeda Talib
notably Biden advisor AOC Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez a former Clinton and Eric
Holder spokesperson Brian Fallon wanting
to defund our police across this country
it is extraordinary and when you think
the left has gone far and they couldn't
possibly go farther because we all
remember the defund ice movement they
want to defund immigration and custom
enforcement and now they wanted to fund
the police this is extraordinary this is
rolling back the protective layers that
protect Americans in their homes and in
their places of business he's appalled
by it and it's remarkable to hear this
coming from today's Democrat Party as
for solutions he's talking through a
number of proposals no announcements on
that but he definitely as he's noted
recognizes the horrid and justice done
to George Floyd and is taking a look at
various proposals the president agree
with any of the mayors across the
country who are saying I think we can
take some of the money from policing and
put it toward other programs that could
be effective in Community Development
which could lead to the potential for
and what a lesser need for policing well
let's be clear the mayor of LA wants to
defund police take money away from
police a mayor de Blasio the mayor of
New York wants to take money away from
police that means cutting of police a
means reducing police departments that
means defunding police departments if
not getting rid of them entirely no he
does not agree with that and the rest of
America does not agree with that that's
two questions for you as you were going
over your forms and what you think is
needed does the president feel that
there is systemic racism and law
enforcement the president's been very
clear there are justices in society I've
noted several for you that he's pointed
out as a Republican primary candidate
noting the Sandra bland video was
absolutely horrible
noting George Floyd there's a civil
rights investigation into that he
definitely believes there instances of
racism but look he believes our law
enforcement are the best in the world he
believes that by and large they are good
people the 750 who were injured
sending this country from rioters in
antifa in the streets as to be
distinguished from the peaceful
protesters those 750 officers who were
hurt defending our country or heroes as
was David Dorn a police officer who lost
his life and Patrick Underwood who also
lost his life in the last week or so he
doesn't think that there was systemic
racism in law he believes most of our
police officers are good hard-working
people there's a lot of evidence of that
and he has great faith in our Police
Department okay well that's a good
question
does he still believe that NFL players
who kneel as a form of protest against
police brutality should be fired the
president is very much against kneeling
in general the president has made clear
for years that kneeling is tied to our
national anthem that it does not respect
our military men and women across this
country he's not a fan of the kneeling
movement he's made that very clear
particularly because he thinks it's
disrespectful to our military as the
kneeling originated at the kneeling
during the national anthem I think they
should be fired I have no comments on
that he is against the kneeling movement
though as he's noted on Twitter as
recently as a few days ago so yes he has
a fire I have no information on that and
I have not talked to him about that
anything the Democrats policing act that
the administration supports yeah did
that legislation first of all the text
of it hasn't even been giving given to
us I've not talked with the president
about that yet he hasn't reviewed it yet
he's looking at a number of proposals
but there are some non-starters in there
I would say particularly on the immunity
issue you had a G bar saying this
weekend he was asked about reduced
immunity and he said I don't think we
need to reduce immunity to go after the
bad cops because that would result
certainly and police pulling back which
is not advisable so he hasn't reviewed
the legislation but a G bar as a member
of the administration noted this prior
to the proposal coming out does the
administration support the banning of
the use of chokehold
look the president again hasn't reviewed
this piece of legislation the president
is looking at what the state issue
what's a federal issue right now he's
currently reviewing proposals actually
on this very topic about police reform
so I'll leave it to him and not get
ahead of him on that but as certainly we
believe that the appropriate amount of
force should be used in any police
interaction with an individual
two weeks after all of this civil unrest
why does the white matter the White
House not have a plan the president said
on Friday that his plan for combating
racism is a strong autonomy how does
that work well that's an important part
of combatting racism this is making sure
that there is equal opportunity for
black Americans in this country this
president you know we hear a lot of
words from Democrats about criminal
justice reform that they wanted this
well they got it with President Trump
reducing racial sentencing disparities
via the first-step act you know
Democrats talk about economic
opportunity for black Americans on
people in vulnerable communities and
this president has done that with
Opportunity Zones it was a good start in
more than 900 places creating private
investment to help people get on their
feet to start businesses in this country
HBCUs record funding this president has
repeatedly through his actions I stood
up for the black community and a big
piece of that is absolutely economic
reform I'd finally note on the point of
economic reform the u.s. MCA these trade
deals the TPP making sure that didn't
take place that directly advantaged
hard-working men and women in Detroit
who wanted their auto jobs so his
Reformation with trade Reformation with
trade and also Opportunity Zones is
helping to ensure that Americans of all
races have the same opportunity in the
economic place say you will eventually
have a police reform plan he's looking
at various proposals so I won't get
ahead of him no announcements on that
front but he has been looking at them
over the last few days yes there are
reports that the administration is going
to be pulling troops from Germany can
you say how many
and when and where are they going now
what I would say on that is first we
have no announcements at this time I
know there's reporting out there but as
of this moment there are no
announcements the president's
continually reassessing the best posture
for the United States military forces
and our presence overseas I mean we
remain committed to working with our
strong allies we consult Angela Merkel
before making a final decision I'll
leave that to the president again no
announcements at this time just one
final the new Lafayette Square fencing
do you have any indication on when that
might be removed or taken down since the
protests have become more peaceful and
who makes that decision yeah you know I
don't have any announcements with regard
to the fencing that's not something
that's in whitehouse control in terms of
securing the perimeter but what I would
say is the president has recognized that
the protests have largely been peaceful
why have they been peaceful it's because
of the actions taken by this
administration if you'll notice
Minneapolis was in chaos until the
National Guard came in and then it was
secured you had outside here in
Lafayette Park I noted the 750 law
enforcement officers that were injured
across the country
well one-fifth of those were in DC and
the vast majority in Lafayette Park and
once the National Guard camp came in DC
was secure that Monday decision by the
president of encouraging governor's to
surge National Guard made the difference
and the president's recognize now that
the protests are peaceful he's
recommended a winding down of the
National Guard very peaceful protests
over the weekend so with regard to the
security of the building not a decision
for the White House would refer you to
Secret Service and Park Service's on
that but the president has recognized
the peaceful protesting and I'm his
encouraged by that
yes Geoff Keighley on Hongkong
when will the administration revoke Hong
Kong's trade status and also do you
think that that move would be the only
thing the administration does is there
something else planned and do you think
that China will listen are you seeing
any signs of trying to relented on Hong
Kong yeah we haven't seen any updates
from China thus far no announcements
with regard to the timing of that but
the president has been very clear that
China's replaced its promise of one
country two systems' with one country
one system which is what led the
administration to make the announcement
that it would begin eliminating policy
exemptions that were given to Hong Kong
the special treatment that they once had
a week after what we saw a lot day apart
last Monday night there eight people
here in this building who believe that
if does the president believe that
perhaps things went the way they
shouldn't have gone
is there any regret on the part of the
President or anyone here about how
people were treated people who are
peacefully protesting and how they were
rushed out so violently no there's no
regrets on the part of this White House
because look I'd note that many of those
decisions were not made here within the
White House it was a G bar who made the
decision to move the perimeter Monday
night Park Police also had made that
decision on independently when they
solve the violence in Lafayette Square
and when before these protesters were
moved by Park Police and they issued
that tactical order there were three
loud warnings and as I believe it was AG
bar on Face the Nation noted that some
of those protesters move back and adhere
to the warning but others of those
protesters started hurling objects and
that was unacceptable and park police
acted as they felt they needed to at
that time in response and we stand by
those actions the country in the world
saw the this violent clash between
people who were otherwise peacefully
protesting but really the president is
not sorry for the way things went no the
president is sorry about the fact that
an tyfa wreaks havoc in our streets and
the failure of some members of the media
to note that like CNN's Chris Cuomo said
show me where it says protesters are
supposed to be peaceful well I'd point
him to the First Amendment where it says
that you have the right to quote
peaceably assemble he should go back and
read the Constitution on
there are many others out there like Don
Lemon saying that ridings a mechanism to
restructure our country burning down st.
John's using a pictu to literally like
carve out as we saw in that video
concrete from the sidewalk to hurl at
officers that's not peacefully
protesting the actors of actions of the
rioters were not in keeping with the
First Amendment and I think the media
needs to recognize there's a discernment
between the peaceful protestors many of
whom I've seen and the rioters and yes
America will act against rioters and yes
under President Trump he will not allow
burning buildings 150 federal buildings
to be deface and 750 law enforcement
officers to be injured in our country
can I ask you one more time I just I
like the blue suit just to follow up on
that
you do know that the burning of st.
John's happened on Sunday nights and a
lot of the violence that you're talking
about that happen on Sunday night what
he was asking about with Monday when as
anyone
their nose it was almost exclusively
peaceful especially the moments before
the chemical munitions we've used on
those protesters so do you just want to
clarify that about the burning of st.
John's is that happened on a different
day
yeah the burning of st. John's is what
prompted the decision to move the
perimeter it's what prompted park needs
to say that evening the perimeter must
be moved it's what prompted yes to a
prompted AG bar to agree with that
decision on Monday morning that the
perimeter needed to be moved but when
you hurl objects at Park Police when you
don't move after three orders are given
park police acted appropriately when the
shield of Park Police was batted down
when one person tried to grab a Park
Police officers weapon that's not
peaceful by any definition of the word
area in front of the White House is now
officially known as blacklivesmatter
Plaza does the president agree with that
decision I haven't talked to him about
it
have I mentioned that to him yes okay I
disagreed in general the way that Mitt
Romney stated over a weekend she does
with the core message of black lives
matter yeah Mitt Romney can say three
words outside on Pennsylvania Avenue but
I would note this that President Trump
won eight percent of the black vote Mitt
Romney won two percent of the black vote
I believe president Trump people across
the country recognized that while Mitt
Romney has a lot of words notably he
said that 47% of the nation is dependent
upon government believes they are
victims believes that the government has
a responsibility to care for them those
were Mitt Romney's words not too long
ago the president takes great offense to
those words that's not America guess
what America is it's when given
opportunity via a trump opportunity's
own belief that Americans of all races
can rise to the occasion and achieve
belief in HBCUs and giving fun defunding
record funding to HBCUs because we need
to enable an education in our country
and school choice those kind of actions
on the part of the president stand in
stark contrasts with the very empty
words of Senator Romney yes thank you
and know that the president's talked
about the protest he's talked about the
death of George Floyd but he still has a
given a formal address to the nation why
has that an order plans for him to do
that anytime soon so the president has
addressed the nation on this I know
several media outlets chose not to cover
it but when he was down at in Florida
last Saturday he said and I have the
whole thing here as he said many times
the death of George Floyd on the streets
of Minneapolis was a grave tragedy it
should never ever have happened he spent
several minutes going through this in
fact half of his speech saying I
understand the pain that people are
feeling we support the right of peaceful
protesters we hear their pleas and he
went on and on and on he said on Monday
I am your president of law and order and
an ally of peaceful protesters so he has
said it some of the media have chosen
not to cover it those words are out
there and they're documented yes Anthony
thank you obviously we're hearing a very
optimistic message from the president
about the jobs numbers and the stock
market recovery but in a executive order
on Thursday night the president said
that he had determined that without
intervention the u.s. faced the
likelihood of a long economic recovery
with assistant high unemployment I'm
just wondering why we're hearing true
messages from the president and how the
American people are supposed to feel
about the economy for the rest of me do
you know the President sees Friday as a
great stride toward what he ultimately
wants which is this rearing economy that
we had where paychecks were growing and
at the fastest for low-income workers
we're at a very good place before he
chose to stop the economy to save 2.1
million lives potentially so he took the
action that was necessary at the time he
wants to get us back to that place we
were at he's the one who can do it he's
noted there's going to be a time of
recovery he thinks that you know q4 will
be good next year will be great Monday
was a great I'm an unexpected note that
the market believes in this president
that employers believe in this president
that baby they believe they can open
their doors in the Trump economy so it
was a note of a great first step of
progress but rest assured there are many
more steps that we have to take to get
back to the hottest economy of modern
history but we will get there under
President
yes sir sticking with the economy New
York City began over reopening its
economy today after a very long lockdown
does President Trump think we need
another coronavirus stimulus package and
if so what would he want us to get it
before he signed it yeah he's remained
open to a phase four there was some
discussion about this there's a meeting
last week at the White House about that
actually so I won't get ahead of him but
he has said there are several things he
wants payroll tax holiday was one of
them because that directly advantages
low income workers several other things
that he would like to see in the package
won't get ahead of him but he certainly
still open to a phase four but it can't
be as he's noted just stayed in local
bailouts for blue states that have run
their states into the ground because of
decades of Democrat policies shanell
Thank You Jamie would president Trump
supports an actual increase in finished
funding to help offset some of the
damage that's that could be waged on
departments that are defunded across
yeah so again that would be getting
ahead of the president on that exact
proposal but he's been very clear he
does not support defunding the police in
any way shape or form he noted in fact
just a little bit ago to me that we have
seen violent crime couldn't come down in
this country and why at the time when
violent crimes coming down why would we
defund the police who are in large part
responsible for helping America to get
to a place where our streets are safe so
he I would point you to that and before
getting ahead of the President on a
specific policy on this movement what's
going on how does it impact the crime
scenario here you said sorry I didn't
realize that you funding the police but
how does in fact the crime scenario Rio
Grande votes exactly enough do you think
that will impact the crime
yeah absolutely look our police officers
are the ones who are defending this
country in making sure that we have law
and order in our streets and there's no
more evidence of that than just taking a
look at the raw numbers they are police
are described as the blue line and
American society between peace and chaos
between order and anarchy and that thin
blue line has done quite a bit just
looking at 20 18 numbers murder arrest
11 1970 robbery arrest 88,000 130
aggravated assault 395 thousand 800
violent crime arrests 495 thousand 900
that's police officers who are doing the
arresting you eliminate police officers
you will have chaos crime in anarchy in
the streets and that's something that's
unacceptable to the president
Selenia political in nature with
politically motivated this movement this
movement what the President believes is
look when you look at I would just take
at their own words black lives matter DC
and black lives matter DC said black
lives matter means to fund the police so
if that's what the movement means of
course the president stands against
defunding the police all black lives
matter including the life of David Dorn
who perished in the last week and a half
and
Patrick Underwood who also lost his life
on this week all black lives matter but
in terms of the movement black lives
matter they defined themselves as defund
the police and that's something this
president stands against Frank yes
blacks are disproportionately arrested
and disproportionately incarcerated in
this country and when they return to
society they are often denied the right
to vote sometimes for the rest of their
lives is the president concerned about
this disparity disparity and does the
president favor restoring the rights of
all those who complete their sentences
so that they can participate in the 2020
election so I haven't spoken to him on
that issue specifically but what I would
note is your question does edge on the
notion of criminal justice reform
obviously someone who's wrongfully
incarcerated that we need to address
that situation and the president has
with the first-step Act a great piece of
legislation that says pregnant women
can't be shackled when they're having
their baby in jail these are basic
common-sense human decency reforms that
the president put in place the
sentencing disparities that are at play
because of the Violent Crime Control and
Law Enforcement Act of 1994 that crime
bill which has been derided and
rightfully so by civil rights leaders
this president helped in part to rectify
that and I'd note that the first step
back the beneficiaries more than 90%
have been black Americans so this is the
president who's always stood on the side
of justice but I have not spoken to him
about that specifically um is there
anyone who is honorable gotten spirited
yes Emily thank you I'd like to ask a
question
myself and then one from a colleague who
can be here sure so many complaints were
made against Eric Chauvin prior to the
death of towards Floyd and I was
wondering if President Trump believes
that disciplinary records and complaints
against police as well as police
personnel file should be accessible to
the public states have different laws on
this but should there be a minimum
national standard on police transparency
with respect to these complaints and
records yes it's a good question but
again it would get to what the president
is going to propose going forward so I
won't address that or get ahead of that
but the particular incidents you
reference of George Floyd it was
egregious and that needs to be looked at
and is being looked at not just at the
state level but I did level of the DOJ
as well thank you and from a colleague
does president Trump urge Prince and Rio
to comply with his Department of
Justice's request for an interview in
the case against Jeffrey Epstein I
haven't spoken to him on about that so I
would not get ahead of him on that John
is there any thought being given to
returning to not a daily coronavirus
briefing frequent coronavirus briefings
and on the reopening the president said
some weeks back that he would continue
to monitor the situation and that if any
states were doing things but he didn't
think were appropriate he would step in
to intervene as the president in any of
these reopening really particularly as
coronavirus cases are increasing which
could be doing part due to increased
testing is he seeing anything that gives
him concern so I would note this first
my doctor burk sent me some new
information before coming out here that
new cases have stabilized and many of
the new cases are being identified
through proactive monitoring and finding
asymptomatic cases today we saw the
lowest new mortality report since the
end of March less than 500 and testing
continues to expand with over 20 million
done and more than six percent of
Americans being tested and in seven
states nearly 10% of the population so
we are heading in a positive direction
even as we began to safely reopen
the president seen anything that causes
him concern I would note again the
encouraging signs put forward by dr.
Burks Sam he's seen the country safely
reopened and I would also just note some
of the media contradictions here
certainly not referring to you
specifically John but just a little more
broadly that there isn't an outcry about
social distancing among the protests and
I mean I saw one Network with footage of
the Ozarks and complaining about social
distancing and those arcs and then
seamlessly transitioning into protest
footage and not suggesting that there
was a problem with the lack of social
distancing so I think we have to be very
consistent here and one note that I
really wanted to get in shouldn't we've
done it earlier but I think it's
important it's just there's so much
focus on our police officers right now
there are absolute cases of injustice
--is our heart breaks for those cases
but I just want to note some of the
great things our police have done last
year alone an Alaska retired cop cam
Castro jumped in freezing water to help
victims to safety after a plane crash in
Idaho a woman said he saved my son's
life commenting on a cop who saved her
disabled son and Maine a detective was
killed while helping a motorist in Rhode
Island a baby who was choking was saved
by an officer in Maryland an officer was
hailed for intervening in an active
shooting incident North Carolina police
ported a mass shooting in Ohio police
took down a mass shooter at a bar in
Wisconsin a terminally terminally ill
girl was visited by 40 officers and
canines and New York officers buys an
officer Roman of the NYPD responded to
an incident involving a homeless man
they bought him new glasses a haircut
and a new suit and they helped him to
find a job in Detroit Michigan an
officer helped a homeless man struggling
to shave in the streets and Virginia
officers could be seen playing with
little girls playing dolls with them on
the street in an Arizona Charlie called
911 asking for a happy meal mistakenly
mistakenly and police delivered this is
who our great law enforcement officers
are and we should remember that thank
you so much
you
[Music]
Elysee Elysee shows up at home as me